(bell ringing)
- [Boy] Oh no he didn't, that is so harsh!
- [Valentina] Right?
- [Boy] Your dad took your phone away
just for getting a D on the history test?
- [Valentina] Yep.
- [Boy] My mind is blown.
- [Valentina] Mine too.
- [Boy] I mean that was an easy test.
- [Valentina] What?
- [Boy] I can't believe you got a D.
- [Valentina] Hey that's not really the-
- [Boy] And your dad is
the school principal,
and he took your phone away, whoa.
- [Valentina] You know,
this isn't really helping.
- [Boy] Your life is so bleak right now.
- [Valentina] Well, thank you so much
for your encouraging words.
- [Boy] What did I say?
(upbeat music)
Hey Jamilla.
- [Jamilla] Hey friends.
What's with the face of doom, Valentina?
Have you been eating
those poisonous apples
from the tree behind the bleachers again?
- [Valentina] My dad took my phone away.
- [Jamilla] Yikes! Glad I'm not you.
- [Valentina] (sighing)
What do I have to do
to get some sympathy around here?
(vibrating)
(laughing)
- [Jamilla] Sorry, what were you saying?
- [Valentina] Ugh, never mind.
- [Principal Rosario]
Attention Eagleton Huskies.
Last night the school
board voted to regulate
cell phone usage during school hours.
Starting immediately, this lunch time.
- [Boy] Uh, what?
- [Principal Rosario] Research shows
that cell phones are distracting,
isolating, and can get in the way of work.
To this end, we will be
imposing a new policy
here at school.
- [Jamilla] Did you know about this?
- [Valentina] What? No!
- [Principal Rosario] In
order to maximize learning,
and eliminate distractions,
there will be no cell phone
usage during class or lunch.
All teachers are in line
on this new approach,
and the policy will be strictly enforced.
- [Valentina] Well this
just gets better and better.
- [Principal Rosario]
Thank you for listening,
now put your phones away.
- [Jamilla] Unbelievable, did he just?
- [Valentina] He did.
- [Boy] I'm calling my lawyer.
- [Jamilla] You don't have a
lawyer, you're 12 years old.
- [Boy] Oh yeah, but the point is,
this is America, land of the free.
What kind of freedom is this?
- [Jamilla] Well, Valentina?
- [Valentina] Well, what?
- [Jamilla] What are you going to do?
- [Valentina] Me?
- [Jamilla] Last time I checked,
Mr. Rosario was still your dad.
And it was you flunking the history test
that gave him this idea
in the first place.
Your problem, you figure it out.
(sad music)
Can you believe it?
They confiscated my phone
because I took it out
for literally four seconds
to check a text from my mom.
- [Boy] Ugh, that's just wrong.
I mean what if it was a
serious emergency or something?
- [Jamilla] Right?
I don't know how much
longer I can take it.
It's such an inconvenience
to wait until after school
to check my texts or contact my friends.
Plus now I have to write
down my assignments,
which takes forever.
It was so much faster
to just take a picture.
- [Boy] Like do they want us
to go back to the Stone Age,
or what?
- [Valentina] Hey, hey, I figured it out.
- [Boy] What?
- [Valentina] Jamilla
said this was my problem,
so I came up with a plan.
- [Jamilla] This had better be good.
- [Valentina] Oh it's good.
You know how my dad said
he was banning cell phones
because research said
they were distracting?
- [Jamilla] How could I forget?
- [Valentina] But what was
he doing when he said that?
- [Boy] Being an evil dictator.
- [Valentina] No, he was
using reasons and evidence.
And that is what we're going to do too.
- [Boy] You mean?
- [Valentina] That's right.
We're going to write
an argumentative essay.
- [Jamilla] Is this a joke?
- [Boy] No, it's genius.
You're a genius Valentina.
We'll turn their own weapons against them,
and crush them mercilessly.
- [Jamilla] With what?
A topic sentence?
- [Valentina] Exactly!
But first, we've got to come up with
our full list of points.
So, are you guys going to help me or not?
- [Boy] I'm in.
- [Valentina] Jamilla?
- [Jamilla] (sighing) Fine.
But if this doesn't work,
you're doing my homework
for the next decade.
- [Valentina] It's a deal!
Now let's do this.
(upbeat music)